he's right Thompson ESPN senior writer
his most recent story a history of
flight traces Michael Jordan's family
relationship with rural North Carolina
also coming out in November penguin
press will publish his next book
pappyland a story of family fine bourbon
and the inheritance that matters the
most and Wright Thompson joins us now
whoa
you're on the beach what are you doing
on the beach I don't know but I need one
of those Trager grilles man we we have a
toddler and so I thought if we didn't
get out of our house after 70 days like
devolve into like some Lord of the Flies
stuff so we're Fort Morgan Beach Alabama
you got your Atlanta Braves Jersey what
year is that Jersey from oh that would
be 1982 that was a real team Dan that's
we got caught el Washington Bob Horner
Chris Chambliss Rick mailer Pasquale
Perez Bruce Benedict behind the plate
Dale Murphy the greatest living American
Oh what is what is the drink you're
gonna have after this interview is over
because you look like you're ready for a
drink there this it's sunny you got your
hat on your shades on it's 10:30 in the
morning the very moment I hang this up
I'm getting a nice cold Budweiser I just
figured last thing in the world I need
is an email from you in PR oh all right
now let me dive into this you came out
with this article on Michael Jordan the
history of flight the timing of this
based off the last dance the documentary
was this planned all along or just
coincidental now it was planned I mean
it started my editor is a guy named Eric
Neal and you know we're watching the doc
and sort of like whoa there relentlessly
beating this drum about how he is you
know to the point it became a meme like
god somebody tell Michael Jordan
coronavirus was talking smack about it
you know and we were like what is it
that we're watching exactly where does
it come from and what does it mean and
so the story really
load out of those questions and you know
trying to understand the cultural moment
that we were all living it and and the
further and further I went back into his
history the more the docs started
connecting for me and it it's weird I'm
sure you've had these stories in your
career but the more I learned about his
family history just the more I wanted to
be a custodian of that story and just
try to deliver it honestly and tell
people what his roots were like and I
felt I don't I felt a great
responsibility to get that right but
what was it that you on earth that that
was one of those epiphanies that said oh
that explains this well then for for
five or six if you count Michael
generations they have lived in a pretty
narrow wedge of North Carolina he's
often people say he's from Wilmington
and that's true but not really I mean
his family is from the country outside
of Wilmington and when you see Michael
Jordan as country and when you see
Michael Jordan is having these long
rural roots and one tight area of land
you start to realize one the things that
influenced him and shaped him to be the
person that we know and also all of the
souls he carried with him every time he
stepped on the court it really reframed
him in a way that I'd never thought
about before
and it was as simple as me going and
finding his ancestors and seeing where
his dad grew up and lived in the
cemetery at the country church where his
dad's buried and literally just putting
those little stars on Google Maps and
looking at be like this is all in the
same place and I mean it was no more
complicated than that at first
why did Jordan do this documentary
that's a really good question I've
thought about that endlessly now I never
asked him because I hadn't talked to him
since it came out but like I feel like
you know the producer came to pitch him
on the morning of 100 bronze
yeah you know like I might have been
born at night but it wasn't last night I
feel like one of the most interesting
things about it it to me is that it
exists and that you know it's important
to Michael that after you know you saw
was at the end of Episode seven when he
started crying thank you how he treated
people and all the dissing cost I mean I
felt like it's important to him that
people remember because he sacrificed a
lot for it and it felt to me that it was
you know an attempt to remind people hey
this is what it was like this is who I
was you know we if you are Tiger Woods
talking about how his kids thought he
was a Youtube golfer Michael Jordan has
six year old twins which my I mean I
have I have a two year old toddler and
I'm just getting crushed I don't know
how he's stupid I bet I bet he's got
more staff than I'm gonna get but deal
right there was part of me that felt
sorry for Jordan in that documentary
because this he we can look at him and
say this made him great I don't think he
can turn that off I I don't know it was
a weird feeling I had and you spent time
with him did does that make any sense to
you I have long felt like Michael Jordan
is actively engaged in what to do with
all what to do with all of the traits
that he's so carefully nurtured in
himself and I think that he has thought
about that since he retired and I mean I
think that's what the Wizards was I
think that's what the Hall of Fame
speech was I think he is actively
engaged in dealing with the idea and the
cost of having been Michael Jordan I
also we're talking to write Thompson
ESPN senior writer he's got a book out
on bourbon well it's not just about
bourbon it's about family it's about
bourbon Pappy Van Winkle and the
inheritance that matters the most so he
also has his most recent story the
history of flight tracing Michael
Jordan's family relate
and chip in rural North Carolina you
hung out with Tiger Woods like the
similarities between tiger and Michael
what is that well common thread well I
mean well couple things one I mean I've
written about Tiger I've you know I
haven't spent a lot of time around Tiger
but the thing that's interesting to me
is that you know they were both Tiger
Tiger was patterned after Michael like
his public life and I think the thing
that's so interesting that we forget is
these aren't widgets just to be replaced
you know like Michael Jordan is an
extreme extrovert and Tiger Woods is an
extreme introvert and so there was a
little bit of sort of lack of
understanding of the person they were
dealing with when they constructed his
public persona and so I mean I think the
way that you know Jordan handled his
better than Tiger and of his because it
was it fit him in a way that being in
public didn't fit Tiger I mean Jordan is
the Alpha in the room you know and in it
so Air Jordan isn't that different from
him and I feel like the public version
of Tiger is very different than Tiger I
also wanted about this with Jordan let's
say Jordan went 4 and 2 and NBA Finals
we would be critiquing him by saying you
know what if he spent more time
dedicated and didn't go out you know
gambling and then smoking cigars and
playing on the fact that he went six and
oh hey you know that just adds to the
mythology of Michael Jordan well it's
like what did Abraham Lincoln say about
General Grant when somebody was saying
like you know he he's drinking too much
and Lincoln was like you I want to send
all my generals maybe they you know
maybe George had the right idea speaking
of drinking can you talk about this book
that you've written on Pappy Van Winkle
I mean we're still finishing it so not a
lot except that it is you know it's a
story about the history of Pappy Van
Winkle bourbon wrapped in with I guess
my own story it's a story about a man
who makes whiskey and about a man who
drinks it and you know I had all these
grand literary
ambitions because it's sort of it's
really John rebending and and I'm really
proud of that part of it and then
somebody read it was like gods eat Pray
Love for men so it's sort of like yeah I
guess it's that too
I did want to like let you know do
something cool for your huge and
sprawling audience of listeners so it's
a it's available for presale now it's
called pappyland anybody that goes out
and can tweet out a like a screen shot
that says you bought it you pre-ordered
it and hashtagging pappyland so I could
find it and then write a sentence or two
about who you want to drink a bottle of
this with and why because ultimately
what the book is about is the community
of bourbon and this thing comes out
November 10th and so just keep these
things come in and I'm gonna look at all
of them whichever one moves me the most
personally I'm gonna send somebody a
free bottle of happy so like you know
pre-order the book write about who you'd
want to share a bottle with and why
tweet it hashtag pappyland and i'm gonna
send somebody a bottle because that's
what this stuff is really about it's not
about hoarding it's about sharing and
it's about sharing it with someone who
matters a lot to you and the rarity and
the price tag on the Bourbon is a way in
which you tell that person you're
drinking with that you care about them
and you love them and to me that's what
it's really about
and this audience responded the last
book you had out when you came into the
studio right dude I walked in there like
37,000 on Amazon and I walked out of
there at number 11 yeah like when
Wallace goes to college because I told
people if you want the perfect gift this
is a beautiful gift that you can give to
anybody the stories that you had and I
said to you look our audience is gonna
gobble this up and I think you were like
yeah right I and this is where I'm gonna
cosign on this again if you want to get
your father or grandfather a a gift this
Christmas Papp
and we'll be that book and it it's it's
not about bourbon but it is it's not
about relationships but it is like it's
it's one of those where you're reading
it and you think you're you're talking
you're knee-deep in bourbon then next
thing you know you're talking about
visiting your father's grave site like
it's the but it's all intertwined and I
I think it'll be beautifully written
because it's by you but the audience
this November look for pappyland but
order it now and then do the hashtag
pappyland
and then let let write see why you would
share that Pappy with and then he's
gonna pick out one and send somebody a
bottle I'm looking at the prices here
Pappy's not expensive right the
secondary market on Pappy is really
expensive so let it's like these are
crazy numbers a ten-year bottle is fifty
one dollars on the secondary market 685
here's a 13-year rise $86 it's two grand
on the secondary market oh but wait
there's more the Pappy twenty-five year
old is thirteen fifty for the bottle
it's twenty thousand dollars on the
secondary market there you know by the
way you know talking about drinking a
bottle with people I care about when the
book comes out on opening day I'm gonna
come back I'm gonna fly out there we're
gonna do this in person like it's
supposed to be done we're gonna go deep
on the whole thing and wait wait wait
what do you mean deep on the whole thing
yeah we're gonna sit deep on the bottle
okay okay so you're gonna bring in a
poppy and we'll drink it on the show
while I do the interview yes
what year are we drinking I mean I don't
want to sell
oh whoa no I'm just saying I just wanted
to know like what 15 a day all right
that's my favorite I had the 12 the
other night I sent you a picture then
I did I liked that the 12 is great I'm
gonna bring a bottle of happy 15 nice
nice and we're gonna we're gonna get
into we might even give Todd some I
don't know Fritzie right well that's not
a pretty picture hey enjoy the beach
once again the book is pappyland also
the article on ESPN history of flight
about Michael Jordan's family with the
relationship with rural North Carolina
and look for pappyland preorder it
hashtag pappyland and right will read
what you say as far as who you would
want to share that bottle of bourbon
with it great too great to talk to you
buddy hope you're hope you're healthy
thank you thanks guys
that's right Thompson if he writes it I
read it that's how good I think he is